（もやし！！）
（もやし！）
（もやし！！！）
（もやしうるせぇ）
（もやし黙れ）
（うるせぇ）
（ぶっとばすぞ）
（もやし！！！）
（もやし！！！！！）
ｵ゛ｵ゛ｪ゛
ホストって・・・
こんな感じだろ？☆
こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
だいぶ中が黒くなってきたなぁ
僕髪の毛の色よく変わると思うんですけど
あちょ
今日パリピの感じで行こう
俺の名前は張日（ぱりぴ）　龍之介
好きなお酒は
☆HO☆RO☆YO☆I☆DA☆
Hey!!Ha!!
パリピ！パリピ！パリピ！
Fooooooooo!!!
Fooo!Foooooo!!!
Foooooooo!!!（レイザーラモンRG）
ていうわけでここ最近俺髪の毛の色を変えてないんだ
Ah
まぁ皆みてもわかるっしょ
なtrrrrrrrrruuura髪の毛の色最近変えてねぇから
そろそろイメージチェンジしようと思って
今日はイメージチェンジの動画よ
（キチガイnow）
やめよう
というわけでちょっとねたまにはイメージチェンジをしたいと思いまして
今日はこの髪の毛の色をね
変えようと思います
SAY！パリピ！！！
別に銀色の髪の人とかパリピっていいたい訳じゃないんですよ
ただ
なかなか銀髪の人っていないし
俺したいんすよ
本当は銀髪とかにしたかった時があったんですけど
なんせその白に近い色っていうのは
キープが大変で
白い髪の毛の人とかいると思うんですけど
アレすごい大変なんですよ本当は
なんでめんどくせぇなと思って結局できなかったんで今回は
これを使っておrrrrrrrrrします
髪色変身
手軽に銀髪
銀髪ワックス
こういう色の人がこの色になります
ていうわけで今日はもうずっと銀髪というのは大変めんどくさいので
これを使えばねもう一時的に銀髪が楽しめるということで
僕自身も銀髪にしたことないしもうしてみたいという気持ちもあるんで
今日は
銀髪になって
パリピパリピになろうと思います
Yeah!HEY!HEY!
パリピのイメージっていうのがいまいちなんかわからない（今更）
わ、すごい
いたって
・・・ですな
よぉーしじゃあ早速つけていこうと思います
すげぇなアニメのキャラクターのようなクールな銀髪になるらしいよ
やっぱなんかね男って銀髪にあこがれるんすよね
銀っていい
金はねぇもうねぇ
飽きた　金にしたことあるんですけど
金はやっぱねぇもうどうしてもねぇ
あるんすよね・・ありそうな
ｳ゛ｳ゛ｩ゛
もうこれつけたらいきなり銀
えぇ？
ﾊｧ?
雪つもっとるだけやん
雪つもっとるだけやないですか
えぇちょっとこんなんじゃないんですけど
何か間違えたのかな？
もっとたくさんつけよう
アホぐらいにつけよう
おいら髪の毛の量が多いから多分めっちゃつけないとダメなんですよたぶん
え、なんかおかしくね？ｗ
ただただ年取ったみたいになってる
おじいちゃんじゃん完全に
まってこんなはずじゃなかった
いやいやいやおかしいでしょ
えぇ？ほぉ、ほn、ほん、コレェ？？
えまって俺もうほんとにもうマジでまっ・・・
もうギンギンにするから（意味深）
もう全部使う勢いでやりますよ
ちょっとまっててくださいね
（乳首登場）
（乳首退場）
というわけで完成しました（パサパサ）
ﾄﾞｩｰﾝ
えぇ！？！？！？なんか割といいんですけどｗ
俺実は結構天パで
そうこれ別に特にセットとかしてないんですよ
セットとかしてないんですけど
なんかくるくるなっちゃうんで
元から結構明るい茶髪なんで
やっぱちょっと茶色い感は残ってますけど
これでグラサンかけたらホストかな
ﾋﾟｭﾝ
うわやばい完全
うわぁ
エスパーの人ジャンこれ
なんか思った以上に割とマシな気がしますね
眉毛が黒いのが残念ですけど
髪の毛セット動画でよくあるあのー
前！横！横！後ろの！
パターンだ・・・
ZE☆（？）
ただなぁ・・・これにすると目立つからなぁ多分
これにすることはないです
ただねちょっと最近髪の毛の色を変えてみたいなと思ったんで
凄い変えれてよかったです今回は
髪の毛染めてないのにねこの一時的に銀髪が楽しめるという
凄い面白かったです
！？
顔にワックスを塗っても銀色にはなりませんでした（？？？）
ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓
さて問題です
はじめんはこの動画で何回パリピといったでしょうか？
thinking time...
正解は
12回でした☆
髪の毛を染めちゃいけないそこの中坊
無駄に高校の校則が厳しい高校生
これは・・・髪の毛を染めていない
是非このワックスを使って
銀髪にして
学校に行ってみてください
殺されます（当たり前）